oh my God there's so many trash
comedians I can't even [__] believe
it if I see another person who's done
standup for three years it's like my
special's coming out in two weeks I'm
gonna [__] become I'm GNA drive for
ups
dude did you know how many times I I'm
like I don't know if that joke's good
enough I don't know if I should do that
I should I put that out and you got
people out there where hey where you
from oh yeah oh you're a teacher oh yeah
whoa
he's all like I'm a
teacher and like oh I just dude this
whole wave of stand I don't even know if
I'll do honestly let me be honest with
you I put out my special I made a
[__] lot of money on my special doing
it my way that's great and it's great
that I made money on it I have money
dude I may not even do another special I
because it's so quick and the turnaround
is
so it's like I see other comedians put
stuff out and it's like oh they're
talking about the thing that just
happened a month ago it's like by a year
from now I do this bit and I've been
working on it for a
year like like I did this joke about the
um the Spider-Man meme where I was like
my my it's in grow or die I was talking
about how my these people are I I say
these three people are looking at each
other it's like that Spider-Man meme
dude I've been doing that since like
that Meme came out and now I heard it's
out on my grow or die and I've been
doing it for two years but like there's
people who are doing that joke now and
it's like I don't think they stole it or
I don't you know I don't know if they
saw me do it and then [__] did it
themselves but it's
like it's kind of not the hardest thing
to think of you know obviously they
probably aren't doing it the same way
I'm doing it but it's like oh you got to
[__] let this [__] be out it's like
you're trying to beat everyone to the
punch and that's what that's what I
don't like about
uh I don't know man I I feel like these
jokes need you need time to like do it
but I guess that's not the [__] thing
anymore I'm the old guy talking now
because it's like that's why I used to
get annoyed with Twitter when I would
tweet it's like people are just like
they wait for somebody to die just to
make a joke about it on Twitter and it's
like all right dude you got your [__]
nine followers from it it was sad that
the person died though how about and how
about just chill and this is a first
draft joke it just happened but then
people became millionaires off the [__]
so it's like okay you got people sitting
in seats because of
this I don't no man